prêt à partir pour une mission de
réconfort entre 100 et 150 en méforme en
uniformes seront bientôt déployés en
pologne afin d'aller prêter main forte
aux ukrainiens qui fuient la guerre
entre personnels fournira une soutien
général des services spirituels et des
soins médicaux
limité avec l'aide de membres
ukrainophones de forces armées
canadiennes
la crise humanitaire continue de
s'aggraver plus de 4 millions de
personnes ont quitté l'ukraine 110 mille
d'entre elles ont choisi le canada comme
sanctuaire les agents canadien
d'immigration sur le terrain ne
suffisent pas à la tâche afin de
contribuer aux soins et médian et au
traitement des réfugiés ukrainien un pas
dans la bonne direction mais
l'opposition s'attendait à plus on ne
sait pas encore exactement quel est le
rôle qu'ils ont joué six militaires la
pologne on ne sait pas non plus dans l'
annonce qui a été faite par les
ministres car ces soldats vont être
déployés ce qu'on a vu la part du
gouvernement libéral est assez assez
timide et des pays qui en font beaucoup
plus que nous en ce moment l'envoi de
militaires pour une mission d'ordre
humanitaire n'est pas la solution idéale
selon cet expert six militaires
débarquent l'oeil donc des combattants
et ils sont susceptibles notamment
d'être une cible par exemple parce que
le y aura des militaires premièrement
dans des missions précédentes des
militaires qui occupaient des rôles de
civils ont utilisé certaines
informations recueillies auprès des
réfugiés à des fins stratégiques et ce
genre de
situation aulas dans laquelle on enlève
les partialité des ongs humanitaires à
travers la présence de militaires peut
créer la confusion pendant ce temps les
recherches se poursuivent abuja pour
déterminer si les civils retrouvés dans
des fosses communes ont été victimes de
crimes de guerre on ne sait toujours pas
quand les agents de la grc se joindront
à eux ils doivent d'abord compléter leur
formation au canada et à l'est
et pendant que nos alliés fournissent de
l'armement de plus en plus sophistiquées
à l'armée ukrainienne
les 500 millions de dollars pour me dans
le budget par le canada se font attendre
ça montre à quel point
le canada était prêt à donner un coup de
pouce à la même hauteur que les autres
pays membres de l'otan les britanniques
envoient des missiles antinavires les
américains eux des véhicules blindés et
des hélicoptères quant au canada il se
prépare à envoyer des caméras haute
définition afin d'équiper les drones de
surveillance ici christian noël radio
canada ottawa